I'm wearing a men's sweater let's judge
fashion Tony Awards happened yesterday
so let's talk about the textiles that
these talented tenth of cold meat sacks
wore
it's a Tony Award red carpet fashion
reveal Midler you look like a baked
potato wrapped in tin foil coming out of
that oven hat
I know it's seemingly not a compliment
to say that she looks like a potato but
I love potatoes they have so much
versatility they're very subtle they
don't need all of the frills and Bill's
to show you how great they are
are you looking to shiny too for a baked
potato okay Ben plaid Oh a navy-blue
tuxedo suit give me that please
he looks like a cartoon human but I know
he's a human you're adorable on a very
accessible level and I like that very
much Kevin Spacey way too Kevin Spacey
just Benjamin Button into Ben Platt in
that previous photo this is the been
flat before you got his makeup done
another navy blue tuxedo suit looks
great but how embarrassing they were the
same thing Cynthia areevo whoa your
chest plate looks so strong this is very
sexy and very strong sexually
intimidating I feel romantic feelings
for you I also feel inspired in a female
sensation from you and I'm afraid that
you could Lenny me Jude nee Benton I
don't know who you are but you look
adorable looks like you just popped out
of that Bush behind you and just left
all the debris on you and like this is a
dress now very cute Cynthia Nixon uh-oh
did you make a dress out of my
background paper that's cool I got extra
cute thrown Johansson whoa sexy power
suit psych it's a dress I like this very
much
you look like you're going to a very
formal business meeting where you look
like a mob boss's wife does very much
professional cute Aven no blaze aha she
was nominated for Best Lead Actress in
Miss Saigon it's just it's very cute
your face looks like you're trying to
melt my brain from the outside and it's
working this is like tribal gothic and
your facial expression is American
Gothic love it Christine Ebersole whoa
this is very Cinderella went to a prom
in the 80s all times in fashion you see
shoulder parents are like higher
shoulders and that's a sign of style but
we always forget what about just
embellishing this arm fat area I like to
think that maybe in her past she got a
bunch of kind of embarrassing barbed
wire tattoos and this was the only dress
that covered that up here Laurie Metcalf
this is very understated a very demure
it looks very elegant you look like
you're wearing one of those expensive
silk bedsheets that I haven't commits
myself to buy off of Amazon yet I love
it Andrew Rannells guys guys was the
theme for men navy blue suits or these
just a series of face off images at them
PLAs don't know but I still like the
navy blue suit plain clothes you look
your age refined dignified also like you
could stomp a [ __ ] very mother of the
bride but this mother is not around you
better make her daughter happy forever
cute just today kissing Olivia Wilde
what do you guys look great this is the
Degas his face looks a little bit like a
Livia wall it's got a finger in his
butthole
but he doesn't totally hate it Sally
Field you look cute and beautiful and
elegant we got a little bit of a tease
prom mother the bride on top and like I
put my lace panties in the dryer for too
long on the bottom cute Tina Fey or did
Sally Field Benjamin Button us as well
what is going on why does everyone look
so similar we got some fringe I think or
feathers this reminds me a little bit of
what my bath towels all look like right
now they keep getting all these stringy
things I think I just don't know how to
wash things I own correctly either way
cute
oh my Thurman whoa this is very pretty
does it look a little bit like the
scary girl that kept to herself in high
school and at the high school reunion
she shows up like this and you're like
oh don't her because she might actually
be a witch how are you
hope you're well we shouldn't make money
it's gonna Cheesecake Factory sometime
please don't drink my blood be Shafer
and Anna Wintour you guys look
accessible and approachable and
relatable and like you're just are fun
at parties you look like you've gone
into a luxury hotels restroom and ripped
the wallpaper off the walls and put it
on yourselves and just said these are
dresses on us now let us never smile
forever cute
Rachel Bay Jones well this is beautiful
you look like a White House
Correspondents Dinner Barbie you Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend you guys look
great you always look good very clean
and like you love each other Chris he's
got kind of like stormtrooper s kebabs
happening like Tron vibes in a very
elegant way and John let's just be John
Legend there's barely a Teddy Ruxpin
doll as a very talented musician does
have a good time Sarah Paulsen I think
you're wonderful you always look a
little sad in your photos but you look
also refined us but this is very
beautiful good job keep up the good work
being and inspiring human thank you
please write back soon Patti LuPone whoa
I thought you were in a cape but it's
just your sleeves are crying fabric Wow
I like this like Victorian jeweled
collar necklace thing and then the
sleeves are just weeping fabric and
there's shoes
all right they're cute Anna Kendrick
what don't you look sexiest floral
pattern dress with a low red bow and
your hair is pulled back and your face
looks like a sexy ant and please Jesus
be my friend at some point in the near
future I like this it's very beautiful
please write back soon Sara Bareilles
whoa this is a dress made of flesh
tattoos look at you
there are fuses to let Coachella die
can't Rachel bloom from crazy
ex-girlfriend
you look so posh and professional and
sexy you would pick a fun mom at the
holiday Christmas party that rented a
sexy power suit from Rent the Runway and
got a babysitter for the kids and this
Jess having a great night I love it so
cute okay well there you go they're my
thoughts on the tone
award red carpet fashions I am very sure
I missed some important people that you
wanted me to talk about and for that I'm
sorry but let me know in the comments
down below who you thought look great or
otherwise subscribe to this YouTube and
please don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel click that button turn
on the notifications because I make
videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes sometimes on different days
other than that I don't know Josh
Groban's they're being Josh Groban
having a great time in Jos Groban at the
tone is you have a lion esque circle of
hair happening throughout the whole
facial region but you're having a great
time it's it looks a little bit like you
rub some balloons on your hand before
you got onto the carpet and it tells me
that's Groban Beach Josh Groban I love
it